researchers trained this bat to slurp  honey water from a test tube and then  caught the feeding on camera why the  bats tongue is a phenomenally strange  work of nature instead of lapping up or  siphoning nectar like other mammals do  the bat transports liquid up its tongue  like a conveyor belt flapping above the  flower like tube the bat dips its long  slender tongue into the nectar and then  just seems to hover all the while  conducting the flow of nectar against  gravity up its tongue and into its mouth  scientists haven't yet figured out how  the bat draws out the nectar but they  suspect it comes from a combination of  capillary action and unique grooves in  the bats tongue  you